this is the mother of my children
and I apologize for any stress that I
have caused even in my frustration
because God calls me to be Stronger
Kanye West apologizes to his estranged
wife Kim Kardashian just do something
for my heart the rapper opens up to Good
Morning America's Lindsey Davis about
the drama surrounding the end of his and
Kim's marriage including his very public
social media Antics I apologize for any
stress that I have caused even in my
frustration because God calls me to be
stronger but also ain't nobody else
going to be causing no stress either I
need this person to be least stressed
and the best sound mind and as calm as
possible to be able to raise those
children Kim filed for divorce in
February 2021 and not long after Kanye
lashed out online a frequent Target
Kim's then boyfriend Pete Davidson who
yay dissed on his channel track easy God
sent me from that crash just so I could
be Pete Davis
and on top of that yay also called out
Kim's parenting criticizing her for
allowing their nine-year-old daughter
North to make videos on Tick Tock hey
everybody I just got off the phone with
Kim I told her to stop antagonizing me
with this Tick Tock thing I said it's
never again
I am her father I know y'all don't
respect fathers and the idea of family
and media tries to promote something I
said I am not allowing my daughter
to be used by Tick Tock you just gotta
roll with it and for Kanye he says it
was all because he wants a say in
raising their four kids do you feel you
have a voice as you're co-parenting now
I do have a voice but I had to fight for
it that hurt you when you when you have
to like scream about what your kids are
wearing the Grammy winner even compares
his battles in business to his battle at
home there was a parallel to what was
what was happening at Gap what was
happening at Adidas and what was
happening in my home it was all a kind
of a disregard for the voice of
something that I co-created I co-created
the children I co-created the product at
Adidas I co-created the product at Gap
there's a parallel and the parallel does
touch on discrimination another big
issue where their kiddos go to school
Kanye fighting for the little ones to
attend donda the private Academy he
created named after his late mom I want
my kids to go to donda and I have a I
have to fight for say so we spread the
gospel we the kids sing gospel to build
a school that gives kids practical tools
that they need in a world Kim has yet to
respond to yay's new interview but we
know Kim's always been about keeping the
peace no matter what we're going through
I always want my kids to be around their
dad as much as possible and during a
recent chat with interview magazine Kim
admitted she only felt like she really
arrived in High Society after she linked
up with the rapper quote he was
introducing me to a lot of people I
think that definitely got a lot of
people to have a different level of
respect
foreign